Of all the effects of the economic crisis
in Europe, the one real scourge is youth unemployment.
Some 5.6 million young people aged between
15 and 24 were jobless in the European Union
in September.
The unemployment rate for them is more than
twice that for adults.
In Croatia, Greece and Spain, half of young
people are out of work.
That's why European leaders have been taking
extraordinary steps to address this urgent
problem, as demonstrated by the recent Paris
Conference on Youth Employment.
Four main measures are being taken to get
young people out of Europe's jobless queues.
The first is the youth guarantee scheme, aimed
at ensuring that all people under 25 receive
a quality offer of employment, further education
or a traineeship within four months of leaving
school.
Second, the youth employment initiative allows
funding from a 6 million euro total budget
for young people in regions where jobless
rates are more than 25 percent.
Thirdly, quality traineeships aimed at easing
the transition from education to full-time
employment, and also an effort to change public
attitudes towards apprenticeship-style learning.
Finally, encouraging young people to look
for work across Europe's borders in neighbouring
states, through labour mobility programmes
like the Eures job initiative.
The portal links users to more than 1.4 million
job vacancies and over 300,000 registered
employers.
These measures are all part of Europe's comprehensive
programme to tackle this number one priority.